What happens when a Desert Eagle is placed
into SCP-914?
Assistant Researcher Erickson place one loaded
Desert Eagle into the Clockworks on the setting
"Very Fine."
The output produced was one Desert Eagle with
no visible changes.
However, when held, it would induce schizophrenia
symptoms in the holder in exchange for increased
accuracy and stopping power.
Assistant Researcher Erickson commented, “It
tried to convince me to shoot Darby.
Despite putting it in a secure storage locker
50 meters from where I am now, I can still
hear it.
I've barricaded myself in my room until the
effect wears off.
I left a slot under the door for people to
slide in food and messages.”